[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous connaissez le sentiment d'injustice
moi je l'éprouvé douloureusement ici
dans le bureau d'un procureur de la
république française dans un département
français en guadeloupe
et là j'ai découvert que le droit civil
le droit pénal le droit international la
convention de bruxelles le droit de
l'environnement étaient des concepts qui
n'avaient pas cours dans les
départements d'outre-mer en grande
partie est là dans le cabinet de ce
procureur je me suis dit rien n'arrive
par hasard il ya un début à tout alors
ne soyons pas naïfs l'esclavagé était
légale l'apartheid était légale le low
cost était légale la légalité n'est
jamais une question de justice retenez
cela la légalité n'est jamais une
question justice la légalité est une
question de pouvoir depuis la nuit des
temps
la société est injuste donc l'exercice
du droit ne se fait que par le pouvoir
donc je me suis interrogé
qu'est-ce qui avait fait que dans ces
territoires le pouvoir d'influencé
n'existait pas qu'est-ce qui avait fait
que des textes qui devait s'appliquer à
la population entière n'étaient pas
appliquées dans ce département
en approfondissant mes recherches je
vais prendre un exemple celui du droit
de l'environnement
vous savez que si vous décidez de
rénover votre maison de refaire le toit
de votre toiture et que par malheur vous
y découvrez des chauves-souris votre
chantier sera arrêté l'administration
sera excessivement diligente la
protection ya but verte de la
biodiversité sera très efficace
on vous demandera d'attendre que les
chauves souris se reproduise
toutes affaires cessantes mon entreprise
devra arrêter son activité et puis dans
6 mois vous pourrez reprendre vos
travaux pour autant que vous aurez
démontré que l'habitat des chauves
souris a été reconstruit ailleurs et qu
elle cette période de reproduction sera
protégé c'est très bien je suis très je
suis vraiment une fervente de la
protection des animaux
mais je suis aussi une fervente
protection protectrice de l'être humain
alors dans d'autres dossiers
j'ai pu constater que des usines pouvait
rejeter leurs déchets en mer
les sucreries rejette en guadeloupe en
martinique des fumées qui sont
excessivement polluantes nombre de
citoyens sont fortement inquiet
préoccupé par une problématique
certaines de cancer peu importe
aucune diligente de l'administration
absolument aucune
une économie coloniale un risque pour
les populations avéré risque avéré pour
ces populations c'est vrai mais elles
n'ont pas de pouvoir l'influencent donc
l'administration ne sera absolument pas
diligente donc cette même administration
qui est en charge la protection
d'environnement va ignorer totalement
cette population alors vous me direz 400
ans d esclavage ça laisse des traces
400 ans d esclavage cerveau exclut les
cercles d'influencé par ce qui n'existe
absolument pas de pouvoir son pouvoir
d'influencé dans 400 ans ou dans ces
territoires
on a tous décidé pour vous on a décidé
ce que vous allez manger on a décidé ce
que vous alliez faire et puis vous
n'étiez même a eu mal dans ces
territoires
donc sujet de la chlordécone tout le
monde en parle de la chlordécone la
corde aecon est un pesticide qui était
utilisé dans les bananeraies pour tuer
le charançon le parasite du bananier et
la baratte leur déconne fait énormément
parler d'elle dans ces territoires et
personne ne fait rien la population est
inquiète dans les antilles françaises
mais qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment passé
dans ce dossier qu'est ce qui s'est
vraiment passé en 1975
retenez cette date 1975 dans une usine
en virginie
on se rend compte que la chlordécone est
un pesticide qui polluent de façon
durable et qui te paie site
excessivement dangereux la population
est contaminé la rivière à côté d'une
usine est contaminée en 1976 la
chlordécone est interdite aux etats-unis
quarante ans plus tard on en est là on
s'interroge aujourd'hui sur le degré de
toxicité de ce pesticide
mais qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment passé
parce qu'en 1975 tout le monde savait
personne ne peut dire qu'on ne savait
pas alors finalement 1990 la france soit
interdire l'usagé ce pesticide en 1990
mais un lobby va faire pression auprès
du gouvernement français pour perpétuer
l'utilisation de ce pesticide alors un
élus des antilles va demander un
ministre de supprimer cette interdiction
d'utilisation de la chlordécone est donc
en 1991
on aura une nouvelle d'une autorisation
d'utilisation de la chlordécone en 1992
en 1993
rappelez-vous depuis 1975 on sait que
c'est un pesticide mortel qui engendre
des déformations
des retards de croissance chez les
enfants et le cancer à la prostate
n'oublions pas que nous avons un nouveau
record du monde
puisque nous sommes une terre de
champions nous avons le record du monde
de la prostate dans les départements
d'outre-mer donc en 1993 nouvelle
interdiction définitive de la
chlordécone
mais qu'est ce qui s'est vraiment passé
et pourquoi cet interrogateur parce
qu'un lobby qu'est ce que le lobby parce
que tout le monde par des lobbys
aujourd'hui lobby on en parle oui les
armes à feu avec donald trump parce
qu'il est effectivement plus risqué
d'aller à l'école aux états unis que
d'aller sur le front en irak parce que
vous avez plus de chance de vous faire
tuer parce que le lobby des armes à feu
il finance les présidents et finance les
élus politiques
c'est la réalité dans le monde entier le
monde entier est régie par le lobby
alors le lobby c'est une stratégie d'un
groupe industriel ou d'un groupe de
personnes qui veut défendre ses intérêts
et qui va défendre ses intérêts en
incitant certains décideurs politiques à
prendre des décisions
des textes qui permettent de protéger
effectivement ses intérêts financiers
alors sachez que bruxelles et la place
par une maîtresse du lobbying à
bruxelles
tout se décide sur tous les états ne pas
ne sont pas souverains sur beaucoup de
sujets celui la santé celui du transport
et du commerce enfin tout se décide à
bruxelles et à bruxelles
vous avez exactement 25 mille
fonctionnaires face à 15000 cabinet de
lobbying et les lobbyistes vont
rencontrer les fonctionnaires mais
attention parce que ça souvent une
connotation négative
non je vous disais les lobbystes protège
des industriels ou protéger les intérêts
de citoyens
moi en tant que lobbyiste j'agis dans
différents secteurs
j'agis toujours dans la protection
d'intérêts général ce n'est pas le cas
de tous les listes mais vous voyez aucun
texte
ne peut aucun texte national ne peut
s'opposer à réglementation européenne
donc la petite histoire de la
chlordécone n'est pas finie elle ne fait
que commencer
et là je vais vous raconter une histoire
c'est que fort de cette interdiction
comment l'état français a fait il a
demandé de modifier le règlement
communautaire ce qu'on appelle un
règlement européen
c'est un texte qui va s'imposer à tous
les états membres à 28 états membres et
que prévoit ce texte ce texte va fixer
des limites maximales résiduelles et
quand on le lit on se rend compte que
pour tout ce qui est produit dans les
territoires exotiques des départements
d'outre-mer
tout ce qu'on va appeler les fruits
exotiques
tous ces produits seront autorisés avec
un taux de chlordécone deux fois
supérieur à ce que l'on pourrait
autoriser pour une pomme pour une cerise
pour une pêche pour un abricot par
contre ce qui pousse sous les terrines
dans les territoires exotiques comme
chez nous les amana les bananes tous nos
fruits exotiques les patates douces vont
recevoir la double peine deux fois plus
de chlordécone autorisé parce que nous
sommes membres de l'union européenne
mais sachez que bruxelles et la place la
plus protectrice l'europe protège tous
les citoyens et à des règles très
strictes
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le
cadre de ce règlement les croates les
bulgares
tous ces pays les slovènes la
chlordécone et savent même pas ce que
c'est donc le texte n'aille au lobbying
pour le faire modifier à l'insu de tous
et aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de la
chlordécone mais ne sait pas que le
scandale ne fait que commencer
mais finalement ce règlement il signifie
que même ce qui vient d'afrique même ce
qui vient des pays étrangers
les annales et bananes peuvent aussi
rentrer dans l'union européenne avec un
taux de chlordécone très important donc
l'impact pour l'union et pour tous les
états membres
il est il sera réel
et on travaille à la modification de ce
texte mais cela illustre bien le pouvoir
des lobbys je vous disais que bruxelles
était la place qui protégeait le plus le
citoyen mais il faut pour autant qu'ils
soient informés de ce qui se passe les
fonctionnaires ils soient au courant de
ce qui se passe et dans ces départements
d'outre-mer qui représentait les
intérêts citoyen parce que le lobby
citoyen est excessivement puissant
pensez bien que la chauve souris
elle est pas venu se défendre à
bruxelles mais les associations de
protection de l'environnement
elles font un travail extraordinaire je
peux vous dire qu'à bruxelles genève
voit malheureusement pas la
représentation citoyenne de la même
façon que l'on avait délégué à sept élus
des antilles ce pouvoir d'aller modifier
la législation française
de la même manière maintenant ça se fait
à bruxelles est ce que vous savez qui
représente vos intérêts à bruxelles
est ce que vous savez qu'en tant que
citoyen c'est le parlement européen qui
représente vos intérêts est-ce que vous
avez qui au sein du parlement discute de
la protection de votre santé de la
problématique économique du coût de la
vie des taxes qui vous seront appliquées
ce que vous savez qui le fait est ce que
vous savez que cette personne est
porteuse d'un stylo et un représente vos
voix parce que moi quand je vais à
bruxelles que je suis sur mes autres
dossiers je regardais je fais très
attention à ce qui va bientôt ressortir
notamment nous sommes en train de
discuter de la politique de cohésion et
établir les prochains budgets les
prochains budgets
c'est à qui ira l'argent aux régions les
plus pauvres sachez que vous avez un
lobby qui a intérêt à faire de ces
départements des territoires très très
pauvres parce que plus vous êtes pauvre
plus vous bénéficiez de subventions mais
à qui vont ces subventions
certainement pas dans nos territoires
ces subventions bénéficient à des gens
qui sont souvent seuls dans le petit
territoire hexagonal
donc il y à toute une stratégie il ya
tout un lobby autour de ces financements
donc à bruxelles sachet qui vous
représente ce ne sont pas des porteurs
de stylos qu'est ce que demain vous
allez faire vous en tant que citoyen
européen puisque vous êtes citoyen
européen
quand je repars de l'exemple de la
chlordécone c'est vrai sur tous les
sujets sur le prix des marchandises sur
le coût des importations sur beaucoup de
choses
il faut exercer ce lobbying citoyen qui
a protégé la chauve souris qui protège
aujourd'hui dans les abattoirs les
animaux et je pense que il est urgent
parce que nous n'avons plus le luxe du
temps de s'accaparer de cette
problématique européenne parce que c'est
là que se discute tout donc je vous
invite instamment à référencer les
associations qui sont dans vos
territoires de vous assurer qu'elles
soient relayées à travers des
organisations internationales non
gouvernementales de protectrice de
l'environnement
oxfam par exemple la fondation schuman
pour avoir des phares des robes de
nativité plus française mais clairement
nous n'avons pas le luxe du temps
400 ans d'absence de pouvoir d'
influence fait que c'est aujourd'hui
c'est maintenant si vous ne voulez pas
que vos enfants demain soit les peaux
plus pauvre de l'union européenne
donc je vous invite à utiliser votre
pouvoir des lecteurs je vous invite à
vous mobiliser auprès des associations
et je vous invite vraiment à militer
pour votre avenir
nous n'avons plus le luxe du temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]